all right do we have any I will teach
readers in the house let's hear it yes
Wow Wow I did not expect that do we have
any I will teach students anyone who's
doing one of our premium courses in the
house Wow in the front row total nerds
okay so I want to talk to you today
about some of the unconventional
decisions we made that allowed us to
build an unconventional business I am
going to take you through the business
I'm going to take you through two key
decisions just two that we made that I
think are really important and you know
I think that if you get these two things
right your business is off to a solid
start so this is me I used to teach
personal finance classes this is
completely misleading because this is
probably the most people I ever had in a
room ever the average number of
attendees was zero and the way I got
into personal finance was when I grew up
I came from a pretty big family and I
needed to get scholarships to go to
college
so I did and the first check I got was
for $2,000 so like any 17 18 year old I
took that money and I invested it in the
stock market this is like the worst
decision you could possibly make because
I lost half of it immediately and I was
like oh [__]
this is not a good start to my financial
career so I started learning about
personal finance and I started learning
about psychology at the same time
and I was studying technology and
psychology at Stanford and you remember
that book the emperor has no clothes
right and they kind of call the emperor
up that's how I felt about financial
advice and everyone out there was saying
don't spend money on lattes and keep a
budget and my friends didn't give a [__]
about that they wanted to go out they
want to have a good time they wanted
their money to work for them so I
started teaching these informal classes
for free and school and usually zero
people came and that didn't work so for
a year and a half it was really hard
because I felt like I had something the
world needed
to here and I knew that it was the right
information but for some reason they
just weren't listening and I later
learned that you might have the best
product or the best information but the
way you communicate it is so profoundly
important and so I created a simple blog
and I decided instead of trying to
convince people to come to my classes I
would let the right people come to me
this is super ghetto blog it was some
template that I found I didn't even know
how to create archives I didn't put any
ads or anything but this is the blog and
I just started writing so fast forward
until now it's expanded far beyond
personal finance and we now have over 20
successful courses I'm really proud of
these courses many of them take us years
and years to test and develop and you
can see that we've covered the gamut of
a rich life there's you know everything
from starting a business to copywriting
to social skills I'm very interested in
creating a parenting course as you know
there's nothing parents love better than
to hear theories about parenting from
non parents so I'm going to hold off on
that one for a while a little bit about
the business we have about a million
monthly readers we have over 30,000
happy customers we recently shared a
post on Tim Ferriss blog my friend Tim
about how we had a five million dollar
week and all the math and methods behind
that so I kind of wanted to let you know
the scale of the business but I'm less
interested in talking about the
financial side of it in fact we really
never talked about our revenue or
anything like that we'd prefer to brag
about our students and and our decision
making behind the scenes so I want to
start with how do you go from that to
this this is the first product I ever
sold as you can see I have a thing for
titles and it was a 4.95 sent a book and
I had been writing my site for free for
about three years I just decided I
wanted to try and see if anyone would
actually buy anything
people were saying nobody pays for
content my biggest fear was charging for
something and then people calling me a
sellout has anyone here had
fear of actually charging for your
product just look around
it's it's a lot of people because you
put it all on the line so created this
ebook sold it for $4.95 and to tell you
the truth the worst of my fears actually
came true let's take a look at a couple
of these comments it's from that day
ramita I've been a big fan of yours up
to now the first thing I suggested
people is to lose the unnecessary
subscriptions and yours would be one of
those such subscriptions just knifing me
in the heart been
sounds like Remi figured out how to earn
some extra dollars on the side I will
teach seems to be more of a product
pitch platform now go [__] yourself been
I've been riding for three years never
charge descent and I'm getting comments
like this what was fascinating was I
kept getting comments like this but
quietly over here people were actually
buying and they bought 100 then we had
500 sale just you know as a modest
number of sales maybe about a thousand
in a year but what I learned is those
people were way more engaged their email
open rates were quadruple the non buyers
and they were just better
they were just better students overall
so I'm like okay this is a pivotal
moment for me I could listen to
complaints like this and basically say
I'm never going to charge again or I'm
going to lower my prize I'm going to go
to an ad model but I wanted to listen to
what the market was telling me and so
this this is a pivotal moment in
business you get feedback but you don't
quite understand what's going on you
have complainers over here and buyers
over here so I decided to keep going I
wrote a book which did pretty well I
went on book tour and I asked people
what they wanted to hear I came back and
I started learning about product
development and building courses and we
built this course called earn 1k on the
side it's an awesome course any earn 1k
students in here awesome look at that
earn 1k we charged four hundred ninety
seven dollars so a hundred times more
this time we still got price complaints
people said that's outrageous maybe it
was fourteen dollars maybe I would
consider it and yet we still had people
buying it in fact we know
that the conversion rate was so high
that we actually doubled the price of
the course and we never lowered it again
so again we're kind of listening to the
market what's going on here and then we
created a different course later much
more high end this was around ten
thousand dollars and for this one more
people than ever saw it and we received
fewer than five complaints about price
so how do you go from a group of people
who complain about a four dollar and
ninety five cent a book to a group of
people who are delighted to pay tens and
tens of thousands of dollars how do you
create a community of thirty thousand
loyal happy customers these are
consumers these are people like you and
me they're in this room and they are
spending thousands of dollars once and
then doing it again and again and in
fact when they buy their top criteria
not even their top five criteria is
about price that's what I want to talk
about today is how do you build that
kind of loyalty and I'm just going to
focus on two key decisions
the first Oh before I go on the thing
that I'm most proud of is these students
and I'm also proud of our team so you
know I'm sort of uncomfortable speaking
out here because it's like seems to be
very roomy focused and I really don't
like that we have a term inside the
company deira meat defying and I think
that's really important so recently
we've started to share photos of our
team and share you know different case
studies etc the team is 100% remote
they're amazing and they're what makes
this possible
these are the things that we prefer to
focus on our successful students our
readers and our team so the first thing
I want to talk about is price so there
are two they're too politically correct
ways in American culture to say no let's
say your friend invites you to he's
having a birthday party he wants to do a
scavenger hunt right it's like dude I
don't want to go to scavenger hunt I'd
rather be sitting in bed reading reddit
I can't really say that so what do you
say you say ah man would love to come
happy early birthday unfortunate I'm
really swamped this week I can't make it
I don't have time totally get it we're
all busy so time is the first
politically correct way of not taking
action and the second one of course
is price and it's interesting you
usually won't see people saying I can't
afford that instead they'll say that's
outrageous
that's too expensive how dare you nobody
would ever pay that anybody have this
experience it's very interesting and in
fact that's exactly what we see in the
data we do a ton of research we collect
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
data points this is one we ask people
why did you not join our course look at
the comments it's too expensive another
pivotal moment here
the world will try to drag you down in
price Silicon Valley will try to drag
you down in price and say nobody would
pay for that people don't pay for insert
blank topic here and if they do they'll
only pay five bucks a month well we
don't believe that we actually believe
that there's there's room in the market
to be the best and we mean build the
best products select the best customers
and service them in the best way we have
no intention of playing in the $5 $50
$100 market I'd rather give away our
content then play in that market so how
do we do this the the key inside I
learned was don't just listen to the
first response because that's
politically correct that's what they'll
tell you but when you build something
that is so good it solves such a big
burning pain in their life then price is
a mere triviality if you think about it
we all this we intuitively know this we
all have something in our life that we
would pay anything for maybe it's a
business class ticket for your mom to
come visit you so she can stretch out
her legs right maybe it's a beautiful
leather jacket maybe it's a bag of chips
you just love these chips whatever we
all have something we pay anything for
and the same can be true for your
products as well so how do you build a
product that solves that big of a pain
point I just want to walk you through a
couple of examples and you can use these
in your product development this is a
survey and when we start off our product
development process we kick it off we
know it's going to take years because we
go through the process we test it we run
cohorts etc this is a very very early
survey that we would send out and you
can notice we're not asking about
our product we don't even know what our
product is gonna be but look at the
questions um what would this mean to you
paint me a picture of what that would
look like tell me how it would make you
feel and then we say here's an example
first I'd be able to do X on on on why
are we asking questions like this number
one we noticed that in product
development people especially here are
super overly obsessed with quantitative
feedback we don't give a [__] about
quantitative feedback in the early
stages we want to know the stories tell
us the emotional stories I came home
from work I have two kids I had to hold
them both of my hands so I can't crack
an egg I need something I can put in the
microwave that just works that's
interesting so we asked him and then
second you'll notice that we're showing
them how to answer questions in the
right way
I think if you just ask people what do
you like to eat they'll be like chow
mein who cares it didn't tell us
anything so we actually show them how we
want them to answer a question and it
turns out people are more than happy to
answer questions if they know that
you're going to be listening okay so
that's like the early part of the funnel
it's really really open and we're just
trying to learn so the second part of
commanding a high price is your product
of course has to be really good so if
you are commanding a high price then you
can do things that others cannot in we
have a course called zero to launch any
zero to launch students in here awesome
okay so zero to launch helps people
create and grow their online business in
many other courses there's a section on
copywriting and they have like five ways
to write better copy we decided to fly
students into New York and rewrite their
copyright they're on a spot in a full
New York video studio just imagine the
difference between a 50 dollar value and
this course which is you know much more
expensive so our competitors are
charging $17 47 dollars $97 one of our
best selling products it's two thousand
dollars again reinforcing the point
there's room in the market for the best
98% of our materials free we'd rather
not play in that mark we just give it
away and the thing I'm most proud of is
that we don't accept anyone with credit
card debt
in our flagship courses so this is all
about your values and I don't believe
that if somebody in credit card debt had
all the information and motivation to
understand interest rates etc that they
would join a multi-thousand dollar
course so we just tell them no and we
tell them use our free stuff come back
when you're ready we're going to be here
today tomorrow ten years from now this
decision it costs us millions of dollars
but I believe it's the right thing to do
and it trickles to every part of the org
the customer service is better our
metrics or everything's better so main
message on price here if I'd listened to
what everybody told me I would have been
sitting you know creating $2 iPhone apps
on the side of a road in some ditch I
don't want to do that okay I don't want
to do that so that's price the second
thing is dealing with rejection
who here has felt some sort of rejection
in the last 30 days with your business
come on don't [__] me everybody does
and you know the crazy part is they
won't tell you the truth they'll never
say you spent the last four years of
your life building a photo sharing app
and the truth is I don't really care if
my photos aren't organized they'll never
tell you that just be like I think the
price is a little high it remember that
five dollar ebook I created I had people
who were like ramita loved the e-book I
don't trust PayPal but I do trust the US
Postal Service so if you could set up a
Pio box
I would in fact I'll buy two copies and
like naive ramita in 2006 I was like
okay so I actually set up a Pio box and
I was like waiting like where's my
bushel full of checks and over the
course of an entire year I received one
check for $4.95 don't make my mistakes
the things they'll never tell you why
they'll never tell you why so I want to
show you how we handle noes
here's a script I'd like to show it to
you this is from a student of ours who
applied for a program he was accepted
and then he didn't join let me read it
to you hi Karthik I noticed you were
interested in testing blah blah blah and
you filled out the application but you
didn't sign up how come the course is
closed now but I just wanted to reach
out
find out what's up so this is written
very intentionally um first people don't
like to be told hey you said you were
going to do something and then you
didn't do it they don't like it but we
still want to find the answer to our
question so we did a couple things in
this email we've tested this when we
kept it really short
- it's super conversational notice the
phrases how come or let me know what's
up sometimes we say out of curiosity
we're not saying you know we're not
being super corporate about it and then
third we have to be really clear we're
not trying to sell in fact the course is
now closed we we cannot collect your
money we don't want it we get massive
responses so if you have had people who
are on your email list or in your
customer base they have not bought
something from you you're sitting on a
goldmine the type of answers we get from
this are amazing they'll say things like
well I'd love to join but you know
course looks awesome but I'm in
Australia and I can't fly to New York
we're like dude it's an online course
but that's not their fault it's our
fault for not communicating that or we
get people who say this course looks
amazing but it's really expensive and I
can't convince my husband or wife to buy
into it that's actually really valuable
so now we can add that to our FAQ so we
collect these data points at every stage
of the customer experience before the
product in the product if they refund
etc etc I can't tell you enough you have
to listen to the customer one more
insight by the way this one was a little
surprising sometimes I learned that
people just aren't ready to buy and
that's just the way it goes like we had
people that have been on our list for
six years they've seen some of these
products be launched like seven 14 times
and then one day they'll just buy
randomly and I see it come across my
dashboard I'm like what is this so I'll
email them hey notice you've you know
joined finally after seven years what's
up and they're like they'll tell us the
most interesting things a big oh well I
tried to do it on my own it didn't work
so I'm finally ready or oh I paid off my
dad or or just because and so my key
lesson from that was just to be patient
if you've put the right process into
place
if you
selected the right customers if you've
built the best products you have the
best marketing our philosophy is it's
just a matter of time okay so the last
point I want to make is what this is all
really about you don't see this in your
Google Analytics you don't see this in
your ad testing when you're split
testing colors or whatever you should do
all that you know you should know your
metrics down cold but these are some of
our successful students I'm very very
proud of them they were able to change
their lives and lead rich lives we did
this by changing from a transactional
relationship to a trusted adviser ship a
trusted adviser think about it how many
people in here have a trusted adviser
you can call up and you know no matter
what they're going to give you the right
information right so surprising there's
a lot of people here as you get older
that becomes more and more rare people
get busy they may have an agenda we
wanted to be that trusted advisor and
sometimes that means telling them no
when it's not even in our best interest
don't join it's not the right course
where you have credit card debt etc
after running this business for 12 years
I think I learned I think my beliefs
changed I believe now that the world
will always try to get you to be vanilla
the world wants you to do everything
like them they want you to lower your
prices the world will pull you down they
want you to make your website look like
everybody else is easy fast secure and
the minute you do it they abandon you
the world wants you to look exactly like
it and the minute you do it they will
abandon you
the second thing I learned is that there
is room in the market for the best
the things that we do in product
development and growth and customer
service and all the groups that we have
it's about craftsmanship it's about
spending whatever it takes to build the
best product we do tests we do a/b tests
we do all of that but taking the time
because when we launch something we know
that it has to be the best that's how we
honor the students who join our programs
there's room in the market for the best
don't ever let the market pull you down
you should
pull the market up with you okay and the
final thing is you're the CEO of your
business you decide if you want to run a
McDonald's type of business awesome
McDonald's is an amazing company if you
want to run a Louis Vuitton style type
of business where you're focusing on
select customers you can do that as well
don't ever let anyone pressure you into
one decision you are the CEO and you
decide thank you very much
I think we'll take a few questions over
here ever meant um so with the rise of
like social entrepreneurship and you
know that kind of build something change
the world change people have you found
that you know I want to help you grow
rich is becoming outdated at all or have
you changed your mind on you know is
growing rich kind of like a Wall Street
fat cat kind of like old cell mentality
or is it still kind of something that is
you see from from your customers well
first of all I love the question and I
hate Wall Street one of the things that
I'm very proud of in my site and my book
is I name names so all the books out
there tell you about banks I name names
of the best and the worst banks and I
believe that there's incredible trust in
someone who you trust actually telling
you the best companies and the worst
companies and most of Wall Street
doesn't like me I will tell you one cool
story and I'll answer your question I
found out from an internal friend that
I'm on a Bank of America influencers
list except it's a negative influencers
list I've never been prouder I've never
been prouder um I said I don't like Bank
of America I think I will teach you to
be rich you know I don't know if I would
pick the same name today I started it
out I was focused on personal finance
but getting up and talking about asset
allocation doesn't drive me it's about a
rich life so since day one I've always
said money is a small but important part
of living a rich life but I certainly
think there's many many more important
things like for me relationships health
where I live all those things are way
more important so we've tried to
redefine what rich means and I think
person by person we are slowly getting
there I hope we are
thanks man keep it up thank you hi my
question is more about lifestyle if you
will so to hustle as all of us do takes
time and it takes energy and I'm curious
if you have advice for people on how to
deal with burnout how to deal with
overwhelm how to have enough brain left
to do the thing that they're trying to
do even if they have the
excuse me almost every time I hear from
someone who asked about overwhelm I and
I dig in I find out that there's almost
always an inability to set boundaries
almost always and that means being able
to say this is what time I'm going to
wake up this is what time I'm going to
end work this is what I'm going to say
yes to and no to the reason that most
people never see me speaking at a
conference is that I just say no to
every single one and I happen to love
salmon I love what everybody's doing
with hustle Kona I wanted to come out
here but I almost never speak I never do
most things that entrepreneurs do
because I'd rather take all that time
and spend it on our students the biggest
skill I would say in combating overwhelm
is developing the skill to set
boundaries every top entrepreneur I've
seen is ironclad about what they're
going to do and they want to do and what
they're not going to do or they're
unwilling to do oh thank you Thank You
IRA mate my name is Jake and I'm I'm a
college student
so of course I'm trying to to establish
myself in certain communities with with
networking getting to know the right
people but my problem is I don't have
the real world experience right now and
I was wondering how what would your
opinion be about how I could sort of
build up that experience and meet the
right people in order to see that
professional growth great question the
fact that you're here means you're ahead
of most college students I think you
should use your secret weapon which is
actually being in college when I was in
college I would send out emails every
week and I had a tab that was called
failures and if I didn't get enough
rejections then I knew I wasn't emailing
enough people so I started to build a
network of emailing CEOs and here's the
magic part CEOs will almost always meet
a college student because they know how
it was and also they want to stay on the
cutting edge of what young people are
doing so you actually have an incredible
advantage and I would use that and just
go there and you just basically get
their brain down listen out of 30
minutes I would spend 28 asking
questions so that's one second thing is
internships internships or free work the
more you can do that better
your skill set will be the better your
relationships will be to thank you for
me yep thank you so you spoke about a
parenting course your mom and dad aren't
getting younger when are you gonna be a
good son and make them some grandbabies
what the hell kind of question is this
that's the last question Oh actually
speaking of that can I take a picture
for my mom and dad they couldn't be here
tonight all right one two three oh my
god amazing
okay thank you guys for that and I'm not
going to answer that horrible question
thank you for that thanks everybody